[Music]
on this Sunday night battle for control
of Sudan
power struggle at the center of the
fighting well it did come through
people's windows and people were killed
and concerned from family far away
a liberal MP not Towing the party line
the back bencher who wants the feds to
reconsider the foreign agent registry
STIs are on the rise the morning after
style pill that could curb The Surge
and waning Wanderlust cause is a big
issue for sure as inflation dampens
summer travel plans the one age group
still planning to splurge
global national with para Nasser
good evening to you thanks for joining
us we begin with the bloody battle for
control in one of the poorest countries
in the world long growing tensions
between rival military leaders in Sudan
has turned violent and is often the case
civilians are paying the ultimate price
the Sudan doctor Syndicate says 61
people have been killed and hundreds
more wounded leading to a brief
ceasefire today so the wounded could be
evacuated with both factions making
competing claims over who's taken what
area it's difficult to get a true
picture of the situation on the ground
but new satellite photos do show us the
damage in the capital city of Khartoum
the black you see is smoke from
buildings either destroyed or still
burning including the Army Headquarters
the defense and energy Ministries
the power struggle is now in its second
day residents are scared to leave their
homes and those watching their Homeland
from here in Canada are trying to find
ways to help Megan King has our top
story tonight
sounds of heavy gunfire were heard into
Sunday evening in Sudan's capital of
Khartoum dozens of civilians and scores
of Fighters have been killed in a clash
that's been months in the making between
Sudan's National Army and a powerful
paramilitary group known as the rapid
support forces
everybody
Sudan's Army appeared to gain the upper
hand on Sunday after fighting erupted on
Saturday between the groups videos
posted by the Sudanese military claimed
to show troops ripping down Banners at
an rsf base and captured rsf troops it
is a very complicated situation
it is too complicated but is still there
is still some resolution I think there
is a resolution for this situation in
Canada Sudanese Canadians like hueta
madani reacting to the Bloodshed calling
the events unimaginable she was just in
Sudan two weeks ago visiting her family
I was in a neighborhood called alhuda
with my list there and who are two
beautiful children
I went there with them two weeks ago
today they had their furniture around
them and they are sleeping on the floor
to make sure that nothing will come no
bullet will come through their Windows
because well it did come through
people's windows and people were killed
the United Nations has even halted its
food program there after three agency
employees were killed it came to
happening during the holy month of
Ramadan which you know everyone is
celebrating
uh instead of that now everyone in Sudan
actually is afraid Canada's Sudanese
Community associations are now working
to send medical supplies and Aid we
established a sort of like supply chain
we know how to like expedite our
intervention in human communicating
crisis like this we will leverage on
that experience to you know extend our
support to like uh
uh civilians and you know uh injured
people over there I mean like all the
crisis happening over there the
community group is also reaching out to
its members across Canada to communicate
the needs of their families that are
still in Sudan so that conversations can
begin to try to help and bring relief
Megan King Global News
here in Canada foreign interference
remains a top issue in Ottawa over
recent allegations that China has tried
to influence this country's elections
the Trudeau government has promised to
tackle the problem head on including the
potential creation of a foreign agent's
registry to curb such influence but now
an MP within the governing liberals is
going against the grain and voicing his
opposition to that plan our Mackenzie
gray joins us from Ottawa with more on
this Mackenzie
well for a back bench liberal MP has
taken the rare step of publicly
disagreeing with the government on a key
part of their plan to try and fight
foreign interference how to wear remp
Chandra Arya has sponsored a petition
calling on the feds to reconsider
implementing a registry of foreign
agents a registry is a misleading way to
identify sources of foreign influence
states to petition we do not believe it
will meaningfully address intimidation
of Canadians and other kinds of foreign
interference the goal of a registry is
to shed light on individuals paid to
influence the Canadian political process
on behalf of foreign countries like
China Russia or Iran places intelligence
officials have warned are meddling in
Canadian Affairs consultations on the
scope of one are underway and it's been
held up by the Prime Minister as a core
part of a strategy on handling meddling
and Canadian Affairs I think it's an
important tool it's not a silver bullet
that's going to save everything but I
think it's part of the toolbox that we
need to look at MPS often sponsor
petitions from constituents even if they
disagree with the contents but that's
not what happened in this case the
person who initiated the petition lives
in Coquitlam BC over 4 000 kilometers
away from arya's riding and the Ottawa
MP agrees with its message there is a
legitimate fear among Canadians
including the Chinese Canadian Community
the proposed registry as a tool in the
wrong hands can lead to harassment and
intimidation of many ethnic minorities
Arya told global news but some
chinese-canadian Community leaders
believe raising concerns of racism is
used as a shield against legitimate
criticism that's what happened the
Chinese government has been doing is
using raising the issue of racism to
deflect any probing into their
influencing of our Canadian Society
numerous National Security Experts and
members of the Canadian Chinese
Community have been calling for a
registry something that already exists
in the U.S and Australia as a part of a
suite of measures the government should
Implement to safeguard Canadian Affairs
it helps clear our name otherwise it
will be forever living under suspicion
that some Chinese Canadian politicians
might be answering the influence of of
the Chinese government
right now the petition has 400
signatures and pharah if it gets up to
500 the government will have 45 days to
respond
so Mackenzie with the issue of foreign
interference still at the Forefront what
could be ahead this week as the house
returns yeah it's really been a two-week
break in the House of Commons from the
foreign interference file for Justin
Trudeau the budget's really been taking
up a lot of oxygen for him he's been
going across the country speaking about
that but there will likely be questions
from Pierre pauliev the conservative
leader to more about the truda
foundation we've done a number of
stories about them here but on Friday
our colleagues at LA Press put out a
real bombshell story saying that back in
2016 as senior member of the prime
minister's office emailed the Trudeau
Foundation asking about a large donation
from a Chinese billionaire that has ties
to Beijing and and why is that important
pharah because the Prime Minister has
said in the entire time this Trudeau
Foundation story has been an issue that
he hasn't been involved with that
Foundation that he had no knowledge of
it and if we go back to Katie talford as
Chief of Staff she testified on Friday
at the House of Commons committee
looking in the foreign interference and
said that they keep nothing from the
Prime Minister and that idea is going to
be put to the test when he gets asked if
he knew about this donation Farah okay
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks for the
preview
clean energy was a key Focus point in
this year's federal budget about 55
billion dollars in tax credits are up
for grabs through the mid-2030s for
renewable resources like electricity
wind and nuclear there aren't many
nuclear plants in Canada right now but
as Eric Sorensen reports provinces are
investing in products that could pay
dividends in the coming years
it didn't get much attention last
December but this was a groundbreaking
moment for nuclear power Ontario kicking
off its first nuclear project in 30
years a small reactor to be built at
Darlington 300 megawatts that's enough
electricity to power 300 000 homes
expected to decline in use nuclear it
seems is making a comeback nobody 's own
we will build a clean electricity grid
said the Finance Minister promising in
the federal budget a range of tax
incentives the Canadian nuclear
Association was delighted stating
nuclear is now recognized as a
fundamental and necessary component of
Canada's low-carbon Energy System the
federal government's approach to nuclear
has definitely changed these new
investment tax credits for nuclear
energy are a huge boost right now just
six large-scale nuclear plants operate
in Canada all but one in Ontario two at
Bruce Nuclear by Lake Huron two at
Pickering and one at Darlington east of
Toronto and one at Point LA Pro in New
Brunswick but four provinces are now
working together and with different
companies to develop small modular
reactors smrs the next generation of
nuclear power in this country GE Hitachi
will build the SMR at Darlington moltex
wants to license a waste burning reactor
at St John New Brunswick out West Sask
power is looking at two small potential
sites in Saskatchewan and in the Alberta
oil sands Pathways Alliance the oil and
gas companies are exploring small
nuclear reactors to replace fossil fuels
we are becoming a global leader in the
growing clean economy it's very
misguided there's anti-nuclear Advocate
says nuclear is not clean because it
creates radioactive waste that lasts
eons and that wind and solar which are
clean can be produced much sooner it
doesn't make sense to build new nuclear
reactors since when the and solar energy
can reduce our greenhouse gas emissions
much much faster and at a much lower
cost nuclear energy has been
controversial for decades but Canada has
a history of producing safe nuclear
power and today it's increasingly viewed
as a key part of reaching Net Zero
carbon emissions it will be years before
next generation small reactors are built
but with ottawa's help they are coming
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
in the U.S it's been a violent weekend
with several mass shootings four people
were killed in Alabama after a shooting
at a sweet 16 birthday party it happened
last night at a dance studio at least 16
others were injured authorities say most
of the victims are teenagers police
provided no information about what led
to the shootings and would not say if
any suspects are in custody
and in Louisville Kentucky there has
been another mass shooting police are
still searching for the suspect who
opened fire into a crowd of hundreds
gathered in a park last night two people
were killed four people were wounded the
attack comes less than a week after a
mass shooting at a bank that left four
dead
this is frustrating this is very
frustrating I know that Monday was a
very high profile event
but for lmpd for Ems for fire University
Hospital for this community this is
every night
this is not okay
this has to change we can talk about the
politics of guns we can talk about
mental health issues we can talk about
the breakdown of the family it's all of
it
police say they have no Witnesses
they're pleading for the Public's help
and urging the shooter to come forward
according to the gun violence archive
there were nine mass shootings in the
U.S yesterday alone the organization
defines it as having a minimum of four
victims not including any shooter so far
this year there have been 163 mass
shootings
a future parents fertility insurance
policy
coming up the growing business of egg
freezing in Canada
foreign
country and the national fertility rate
sunk to a record low last year according
to statistics Canada with couples
delaying their plans for having kids for
a variety of reasons now that's led to a
rise in fertility treatments including
egg freezing Vanessa Wright reports
after a recent statistic by The Who
revealed that one in six people globally
are affected by infertility experts
believe that may explain why egg
freezing is rapidly growing across the
country it's a bit of an insurance
policy for your future fertility an
insurance policy is exactly what 25 year
old PhD student Shania boppa was hoping
for after documenting her egg freezing
Journey on Tick Tock inspiring others
her age to discuss their experience with
the popular technology I'm just so happy
I took the leap of faith hoping that
this will all work out and I'm so glad
that I got to connect with so many women
along this journey medical egg freezing
is usually performed for individuals
affected by pre-existing issues while
social or elective egg freezing is more
common for delaying fertility for
circumstantial reasons if you want to
postpone the fertility because you're
not ready because of a career or Finance
or
social reason then might be worthwhile
to freeze the eggs although egg freezing
doesn't see as much legal implications
as other areas of Health Care there are
ethical ones experts say the technology
is often advertised as a have it all
procedure which may distort the true
costs risks and definitions of success
is Success based on the number of eggs
that are retrieved is Success based on
the number of eggs that survive the
thawing is it based on getting pregnant
there are potential risks that arise and
perhaps the most serious is ovarian
hyperstimulation syndrome it's something
that doesn't happen very often but it's
certainly something that's important to
advise patients about experts suspect
the demand in egg freezing will only
continue to grow in popularity and hope
that the conversation of women's
reproductive health will grow along with
it Vanessa Wright Global News Halifax
[Music]
ahead how a 50 year old antibiotic could
be a morning after solution to Canada's
growing STI problem
[Music]
[Applause]
the public health agency of Canada says
sexually transmitted infections have
been on the rise in the last decade the
infections are quite often curable or at
least manageable with treatment and now
it's Catherine Ward reports a well-known
drug is showing promise
doxycycline has been around for decades
but the oral antibiotic may have some
untapped potential according to
researchers biologically it has activity
against chlamydia gonorrhea and syphilis
our recent study found when men who have
sex with men and transgender women took
the drug within 72 hours of having sex
without a condom rates of sexually
transmitted infections declined we had
enrolled 500 501
men and about about a two-thirds
reduction in gonorrhea chlamydia and
syphilis the drug can treat chlamydia
and syphilis as an alternative to
penicillin but is more commonly used for
skin and bone infections and even to
prevent malaria doxycycline is approved
for use in Canada to treat bacterial
infections but not for preventing
sexually transmitted infections some
doctors are starting to prescribe it off
label I certainly do have patients
personally on this and I I have several
colleagues who have patients on this and
these are people you know who are you
know really do qualify for this you know
they they've perhaps struggled with
several infections over the course of a
year and are really looking to uh are
really looking to be proactive in their
health but the drug may not work for
everyone a Kenyan study found
doxycycline wasn't as effective for
women the disappointing result was they
did not see an effect they did not see a
reduction in gonorrhea or chlamydia it's
also very disappointing
um because you know right now we've been
focusing primarily on one or two
populations here in Canada and the U.S
but um
eventually there's a there's a need in
many other populations who are at risk
as well another concern is whether there
could be a rise in antibiotic resistance
these are the kinds of questions that I
think a lot of Public Health officials
and infectious disease stocks would
really like to have more information
about Catherine Ward Global News Toronto
and maybe a show on Broadway or all of
New York is on your to-do list for
travel this summer but if you do have a
grand Adventure in mind you might be an
outlier because more and more Canadians
say higher interest rates and persistent
inflation are taking a toll on their
summer getaway plans that's according to
ipsis polling exclusively for Global
News and gaviola has more on how the
economy has changed the travel bug this
year thank you
last summer was all about revenge travel
a frenzy of bookings to make up for an
extended period when many were stuck at
home this year it's about dollars and
cents and staycations Canadians are
going to be looking for a cheaper
alternatives maybe they won't be booking
a flight and traveling across the
country or out of the country but having
that break is important for so many
people six in ten Canadians are scaling
back their summer vacation plans
according to ipsa's polling exclusively
for Global News almost all blaming
inflation and economic uncertainty a
quarter say there's no way a summer trip
could even be affordable only 13 percent
plan to spend more this year younger
people who perhaps have less money to
spend on vacation are the most likely to
say that they need a vacation they're
among the most likely to say that
they're going to splurge and take a
vacation this year it'll come what may I
was so shocked at how expensive it is to
fly inside Canada even if it's just a
Newfoundland from Toronto that was
insane if Ottawa was so expensive I
might just go to like Montreal or go to
Niagara we are thinking about it like
trying to put something in place but
cost is a big issue for sure so we don't
have anything set in stone yet what
we're also seeing is more Canadians
paying attention to destinations where
the Canadian dollar goes a little bit
further like the Caribbean South Asia is
obviously a big destination travel
expert Omar kaiwan suggests using Reward
Points towards travel it's always a good
idea to see how much you have in terms
of points and use them as quickly as you
possibly can because these points can
change at any point whether it's the
value of the points and how much you can
redeem hotel prices have spiked So He
suggests Alternatives like Airbnb and
VRBO they can trim your food budget too
if you have a full kitchen in his final
tip what we're also seeing with a lot of
airlines and flight cancellations
especially some of these sort of Cheaper
Airlines that are coming about they're
having some Financial issues and flights
are being delayed and shortage of Staff
research whether medical and travel
insurance May save you time and money in
the long run Ann gaviola Global News
Toronto
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser thank you
for spending part of your evening with
us and a very happy Orthodox Easter to
those of you who celebrate the holiday
especially important for ukrainians as
War wages on in their Homeland so
tonight we're going to leave you with
some festivities in Toronto as Ukrainian
Canadians and newcomers alike celebrate
Donna will be back with you tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
[Music]
foreign